from a deleted murderous opening scene
and an alternate ending to an extended
showdown between scarlet witch and
professor x multiverse of madness was
almost an incredibly different movie
yupikai movie lovers i'm jan and these
are the deleted scenes an alternate
ending you never got to see in doctor
strange 2. spoilers of course so take
care marvel's multiverse of madness had
a pretty chaotic production from
original director scott derrickson
quitting over creative differences to
pandemic related problems and new
director sam raimi having to begin
shooting before the script was finalized
in fact they didn't even have an ending
to the story until halfway through
filming and when the movie's release
date was flipped to come after
spider-man no way home in one division
instead of before as had been the plan
numerous other changes had to be made of
course these kind of situations are part
and parcel of movie-making and can lead
to fantastically enjoyable movies as
well as critically derided ones but
what's the case for doctor strange well
according to raymie his first cut of the
movie was around 2 hours and 40 minutes
over 30 minutes longer than the final
version and we can figure out some of
what was cut from the final film via
missing scenes from the trailers and
early plot leaks some of these leaks
were fairly accurate when compared to
the end movie so what's missing would be
an indicator of changes made due to
reshoots as well as cuts made after
feedback from test screenings one big
change made was to the opening of the
movie which in the leaked plot had mordo
hunting wanda in a fiery burned forest
with a magical bow it seems he tracked
her down to a cabin where she was living
perhaps the one we see her in at the end
of one division mordo tried to kill her
with magic arrows but failed and instead
she ended up killing him chopping off
his head this horror-filled scene set
around a cabin in the woods certainly
feels fitting for a sam raimi film given
his iconic evil dead movies and it would
have followed up on mordo's story from
the end of the first doctor strange
movie where he turned against steven and
later tracked down pang born and took
away his powers why are you doing this
because i see at long last what's wrong
with the world too many sorcerers the
cut scene of mordo hunting wonder would
have in a way paid off this cliffhanger
from the first movie but it seems marvel
decided instead that they want to keep
that mordo alive so he can return in a
future doctor strange film and get a
proper conclusion to his evil mordo
story set up at the end of the original
film another possibility is that the
deleted scene might have felt too
similar to the opening scene of the
first doctor strange movie where the
villain kaiselius and his zealots
decapitated a librarian at the
commantage plus not revealing wanda as a
villain right away in the opening scene
keeps alive a bit of the mystery of
who's behind the interdimensional
monster attacks on america chavez a
little longer
another big change to the movie was made
during reshoots when according to the
hollywood reporter inspired by
spider-man no way home marvel decided to
have more fun with the multiverse by
adding more cameos and characters and it
looks like this changed the illuminati
lineup in comparison to what was planned
in the original script in the earlier
version professor x captain carter
captain marvel were part of the team
however there wasn't any mr fantastic or
black bolt so it seems these were later
editions and that they replaced balder
the brave who was also originally going
to be a member of the illuminati in the
comics boulder is an asgardian and
thor's half-brother and there were
rumors he was going to be played by
raymie regular bruce campbell who also
cameoed in all three of raymie's
spider-man movies however campbell ended
up with the part of pizza popper the
street food vendor who complains about
not getting paid and whose strange cast
to spell on to keep hitting himself in a
nod to campbell's famous evil dead
character
it might have been interesting to see
strange meet thor's half-brother
especially after the sorcerer's previous
interaction with thor and loki in
ragnarok
wanda's massacre of the illuminati
including how she took out charles
xavier was a huge moment in the movie
however in the original plot wanda had
an extended confrontation with professor
x where he floated up to her in his
hover chair as we can see in this
previous concept art his levitating
chair would have been a reference to
professor x's hover chair from the 90s
x-men animated tv show and would have
fit nicely with the theme tune from the
series which plays when charles first
arrives in the film
the ending of multiverse of madness also
had numerous significant changes
compared to the original plot the brutal
battle at camartage where scarlet witch
wiped out almost everyone came towards
the end rather than at the beginning of
the movie and there was also going to be
a scene of rindra giving a speech in
praise of wong more significant though
is that originally after wanda decided
to destroy the darkhold castle and bury
herself under rock we would have then
got a shot where we actually see her in
the rubble in the final movie the scene
ends instead on a wide shot of the
collapsing castle and mountain and you
can see a little burst of red energy in
the crumbling rock i think this could be
read two ways as either wander making a
protective bubble for herself so she can
survive or as a final burst of her magic
as she dies i think it's pretty much
guaranteed that elizabeth olsen will be
back but seeing her in the rubble at the
end might have implied more strongly
that she's still alive similar perhaps
to the end of x-men origins wolverine
where we see deadpool also the villain
of that story as his arm crawls out from
under a pile of rubble and his eyes open
of course if this wander is dead we
could still see olsen return as a wander
variant from a different universe would
you like to see scarlet witchback
comment with your thoughts and theories
below
a cool surprise in the mid-credits scene
is when charlize theron makes her mcu
debut as clear to request help from
doctor strange about an incursion in
another dimension there had been some
reports and fan speculation that rachel
mcadams who plays christine palmer was
going to end up cast as clear as well in
fact since the film's release mcadams
has revealed that she was initially told
she'd be playing three versions of her
character however in the final movie she
played just two versions of christine
one in the regular main universe and one
in the 838 universe who is a scientist
working for the illuminati
there are some interesting moments in
the trailers and promo materials a
footage that didn't make it into the
final film there seems to be an extended
or alternate version of stephen meeting
sinister strange as we never got this
dialogue in the final movie things just
got out of hand
now this could be from a scene that was
later re-shot or perhaps from a longer
version where sinister strange was
explaining how his use of darkhold magic
had gone wrong or it might even have
been a reference to the actions of
strange supreme from the animated what
if series who became corrupted and
destroyed his own universe in fact the
lie might have actually been removed to
avoid confusing fans as some already
thought that sinister strange was the
same character as the animated strange
supreme until that is benedict
cumberbatch recently debunked the theory
and if you're enjoying these rejected
scenes so far do hit that like button
and subscribe so you don't miss out on
new videos like this
there's a short scene teased in the
trailers of wong and strange seemingly
discussing the consequences perhaps of
doctor strange's actions and spider-man
no way home i did what i had to do to
protect our world you cannot control
everything strange from the backdrop it
looks like this probably took place in
the sanctum sanctorum and it feels like
it was likely cut due to being a bit of
exposition that the audience didn't need
interestingly raimi has said that a lot
of what they learn from test screenings
is not just what audiences don't
understand about a movie or what they
like but also what the audience already
knows and doesn't need or want
explaining again or things they can
figure out themselves without further
explanation which helps keep the story
tighter and there was a creepy shot
teased in the trailer of a close-up of a
crow we don't have much context of where
this came in the original curt but given
the reddish backdrop it's probably a
wonder focused scene perhaps a deleted
opening scene where mordo is tracking
her down or when strange visits wander
for the first time and she reveals a
desolate red orchard
now we know deadpool will be coming to
the mcu at some point and fans are
waiting on a confirmed date for when the
merc with a mouth will get his next
movie however there were a stack of
rumors that he was going to appear in a
multiverse of madness post-credit scene
and some fans even believed they could
see deadpool and a shard of glass on a
poster for the film one purported leak
correctly predicted clear's appearance
in the mid credits though some of the
details around it weren't quite so
accurate but it also stated that
deadpool cable domino and vanessa were
in a post-credits scene where they
turned up at the illuminati center to
discover the carnage unleashed by wonder
supposedly deadpool would have cracked a
few jokes about the dead members and
krasinski's best known role in the tv
series the office and then broken the
fourth wall with a comment about how
patrick stewart's professor x was dead
yet again referencing the numerous times
charles has previously died in fox's
x-men movies whether this post-credit
scene was actually on the cards or more
like a wild rumor i'll leave up to you
so movie lovers do you wish any of these
deleted scenes have been in the final
movie let me know below next tap left
for more awesome marvel deleted scenes
and alternate endings like how black
widow almost came back from the dead at
the end of her solo movie thanks for
enjoying this movie with me and hope you
have a marvelous movie loving week
yippie kaio movie lovers